given all the wisdom you have now if you
were to give advice to somebody or if
you were to start over again
uh you had no money what would be the
first 10 videos you tried to uh to make
on a new channel I guess that's advice
for a new person and nobody knows you
yeah nobody knows me yeah like
hypothetically I have a mask on and you
also I guess don't have the wisdom well
if I don't have what I have in my head
then I would say just fail like just a
lot of people get analysis paralysis and
they'll just sit there and they'll plan
their first video for three months and
yeah I'm any of you listening if if you
especially if you have zero videos on
your channel your first video is not
going to give views period it's not your
first ten are not gonna give views I can
very confidently say that so stop
sitting there and thinking for months
and months on end and just get to work
and start uploading like all you need to
do this this applies to people who have
not uploaded videos but have dreams of
being a YouTuber is make 100 videos and
improve something every time do that and
then on your 101st video we'll start
talking like maybe you can get some
views but you know your first hundred
are gonna there are very freak cases
like Liza koshy or Emma Chamberlain who
have really good personalities and it
doesn't take them so as many videos and
it's just like people who are seven foot
five and making an NBA like yes there
are free cases you can find but for the
average person like us you know who
don't have these exceptional
personalities and you know backgrounds
in filmmaking just make 100 videos
improve something each time and then
talk to me on your 101st video well the
improve something his time is the tricky
one how do you improve something each
time the second one just I don't know
put more effort into the script the
third one try to learn a new editing
trick the fourth one try to figure out a
way that you can have better inflections
in your voice the fifth one try to you
know study a new thumbnail tip and
implement it the sixth one try to figure
out a new title there's infinite ways
that's the beauty of content creation
online there's literally infinite ways
from the coloring to the frame rate to
the editing to the filming to the
production to the jokes to the pacing to
every little thing can be improved and
they can never not be improved there's
no there's literally no such thing as a
perfect video
so if you knew everything you know now
but no money step one would I just
brainstorm like okay I don't have money
what are some viral things like I mean
the first thing that comes to my mind is
something as simple as when I count to a
hundred thousand which is what I did do
and I I was poor
um and like that worked but like what's
something like that I could do that
would be even more attention yeah you
were as part of the brainstorm you would
throw out a lot of ideas and people
throw out a bunch of ideas and one of
the questions is this even doable right
yeah first off come up with ideas you
think would do well and then ask
yourself later if they're doable yeah
because there's there's different ways
you can accomplish something don't be
cynical about the doability of stuff
yeah because there really are so many
different ways you can accomplish a goal
like
um
when we give away an island like we give
our 100 million subscribers Island yeah
you know you can't find private islands
that you know don't look like [ __ ] for
less than 10 million dollars so this
isn't doable right all right the idea
doesn't exist not doable exit off but
then you know you dig into it and you
you know find different Alternatives you
find okay what if we just buy a two
million dollar Island that sucks and
then spend a million dollars you know
importing some sand let's build a beach
let's import 300 trees let's put a
little bit of canals cut some pass boom
now it's a really nice Island but it's
actually affordable because we don't
have 10 million dollars to spend on
video but we can afford to spend three
and a half and lose whatever a million
dollars on that video so like that's an
example of like yeah if you just went
off the gut test you're like this isn't
doable you know every Island's 10
million dollars we're screwed like if we
go cheaper it's just a terrible Island
no and so if you like there are so many
different ways you can achieve what you
want you really got to push through
notes which not a lot of people do you
have to have like a more of a dominant
personality and just a willingness to
um when people tell you it's not
possible just actually go through all
the variables and eliminate them all
yourself
have a stubbornness
and uh resilience to failure maybe for
what we do and creators online it's very
imperative that you have
that a no isn't a No Deal you really
have to like think and um and just like
we we take a personality test and like
just having a dominant personality is a
better indicator that when someone tells
you oh there's no way you're gonna build
a brick wall for under 100 Grand you
know you'll be like okay and then still
go check the next 10 vendors and you
know figure it out